[Music]
hello happy friday august 20 health
andrés gonzález and these are the
most relevant news of the day we are going to the
city of program where a dispute
between a man and his girlfriend led to a
shootout with the county authorities
there are no agents of the  night county sheriffs
responded to the house
near vlag and irene streets this was
thursday afternoon according to official reports they
first went to the
girlfriend's house and then the suspect's house
and that's where he shot the
deputies  they managed to get into the house and
discovered that the man had
shot himself the suspect was
transported to serviu hospital where
he is recovering no officers
were injured in the
confrontation nevadas governor styps and solar
say the state will welcome him
of refugees from afghanistan
plus other state leaders are
preparing for an increase in new
arrivals and refugee resettlement as
well  is being
overseen by non-
profit organizations such as
catholic charities
and there is uncertainty about the third
dose of the cob vaccine and 19
anyone immunocompromised
can get the vaccine immediately as
long as more than 28 days have passed
since their second  dose all
other people have to wait eight
months after the final dose before
receiving the third dose and being
approved by the efe hence the cdc the
booster vaccine would be
available after September 20
let's see what the temperatures await us
for this weekend and we reached a
maximum of 97 degrees and an
air quality alert is extended until
Sunday this due to the fires in
california next week we will return
to temperatures in the triple digits so
you have to take care of the happy heat  day
andrés gonzález informed them and this was
about the news now in
Spanish
[Music]